hi i'm shaquille o'neal i'm here in
atlanta georgia that's right the
football stadium is behind me i'm at one
of my favorite restaurants in atlanta
georgia
restaurant 10. of course they've been
hit pretty hard during the pandemic
but we got a surprise for them my name
is lori clay
and i am the executive chef of platt
restaurant group good morning team you
guys are going to have our
powwow this morning find out what
today's specials are
[Music]
we have been open now going into our
third year
our owners were born and raised in this
community it was imperative that they
put back into the community so that's
why they built this restaurant
we do a lot of catering for the area
schools
and the wise you name it so we just
really
just involved so i always say about
mid-february you know the word was
getting out you know we're gonna have to
possibly close if something's going you
know the pandemic is coming et cetera
you know we had a pretty good amount of
folks that you know had to go home
and not a lot of them were able to meet
all of the unemployment guidelines
so they were some some employees were
without funds at all
we just kept going and trudging through
some weeks you know we get
maybe 10 20 customers it was
very very very slow so when we hung in
there
we wouldn't have made it without the
community the community kept us afloat
we just want to get back to normal just
a little bit it's tough
but i mean it is what it is
[Music]
we have a lot of celebrities that come
through here
shaquille o'neal love our fried chicken
and our collard greens so
we definitely have him come back hello
i just told him about how you like her
our fried chicken
i didn't know you were coming in here
though sir oh you lady always cooked my
food
absolutely as a matter of fact he's the
one that inspired us to change our menu
because he came in
he says i want some fried chicken and we
were like
okay and now it's a part of our 2021
menus
so we have southern fried chicken on our
mini oh you guys yes sir
i hear doing a pandemic you guys ain't
really been doing too well you know how
difficult it is
it's just a matter of trying to you know
show that we're trying to be
safe and get people to come in and see
us and things like that you know i have
a present for you later
um i really do i got a big present i
mean you know what i'm gonna do for you
today
i'm gonna feed you today oh
[Laughter]
first thing we do is we wash our hands
okay okay
because the glove don't fit and you
can't cook
then we're gonna bring the rings up
we're gonna let them drain
good job all in the wrist there you go
you sit them in the window and you like
them with blue cheese and ranch i like
uh
neither neither all right so
shack no sauce what is that curd great
okay that's nice right there then it's
ready to serve
everybody got a fork
best macaroni in atlanta alisha
come on in this is alicia hi
good night we surprised you today
you did we heard you talking about this
cornbread
yes but we also heard that you might
need a warmer yes ma'am that's for sure
the general insurance is here to give
people a break and so we're going to
leave you with
a bread warmer for you but that's not it
we know this staff has been working
overtime and we're going to leave you
with an employee relief fund
oh my goodness 35 000. an employee
relief pump for 35 000.
you can bless your staff because they've
been blessing this community
thank you so much let me tell you
something these guys you have
no idea how they've been working under
staff
staying here trying to get it done
trying to learn come up to the stand to
train new people it's just been a lot
so i think this is one of the best
things you guys could have ever given us
because nobody's had really much time
off and we greatly appreciate it
don't cry yeah kids
big dog get some more macaroni boy i'll
start my diet tomorrow
we all have been hoping for some relief
just just a little bit of relief would
be helpful i mean with that being said
we want 2021 to be our best year
bang bang boy